remember the internationally celebrated
Egyptian revolution of 2011 where young
activist led a popular uprising that
ended 30 years of Hosni Mubarak
autocratic rule and remember how around
900 protesters were killed well nearly
four years later those celebrations are
long dead as are the hopes for justice
for those killed or so it seems no one
is being held responsible to date for
those deaths after a judge threw out all
charges against Mubarak and acquitted
his top aides in the killings of the
nearly 900 protesters Karger based
journalist Sharif LeDoux's tweeted chalk
it up to mass suicide that cynicism was
echoed in Egyptian press with numerous
headlines asking so who is the killer
but maybe the better question to ask to
understand what's going on in Egypt
right now is who's in jail and who is
not well for starters Mubarak and the
head honchos of his regime are basically
out of jail including the police chief's
who oversaw security during the 18 days
of the revolution Mubarak remains on
house arrest in a military hospital so
who is in jail then well a lot of the
left-leaning activists who led the
revolution in 2011 they're in there in
large part thanks to a 2013 law that
effectively gives the government free
rein to ban any protest it deemed
threatening until anyone who doesn't
comply
Human Rights Watch estimates hundreds
have been arrested for breaking this law
that includes the leaders from the April
6 youth movement one of the main forces
that pushed for the revolution in 2011
but has since been outlawed by the state
who else is behind bars Mohamed Morsi
Egypt's first democratically elected
president who was overthrown in a
military coup in July 2013 one year
after taking office also jailed are most
of the leadership of his fellow Muslim
Brotherhood which the government also
outlawed after declaring it a terrorist
organization
this on top of the life sentences that
over a hundred of them have already
received not to mention the mass death
sentences a lot of the Brotherhood
supporters who protested have also been
swept up in jails in fact more than
15,000 since July 2013 so nearly four
years since the revolution Egyptians and
folks around the world are reflecting on
where the country now stands political
cartoons like these have popped up on
social media making a point that Egypt
is perhaps right back to where it was so
the revolution was televised but is it
now off the air for goods where do you
think it goes from here this will go
over to gamma you go over to this Renea
collapse hello sir Jerry get em